100 millones de usuarios en 40 países se
ha convertido en la mayor aplicación de
viajes compartidos del mundo una serie
de archivos confidenciales filtrados
muestran que uber utilizó métodos
potencialmente poco éticos para impulsar
su rápida expansión global obtenidos por
the gardian los 124 mil documentos que
han sido bautizados como archivos uber
revelan que el gigante tecnológico se
saltó las leyes presionó a los gobiernos
e incluso cortejó a los políticos para
forzar su servicio en todo el mundo como
un aliado particular que se encuentra en
el presidente de francia enmanuel macrón
lo que hace que otros políticos se le
acusen de saquear al país
estas son revelaciones condenatorias
sobre el papel activo que juego emanuel
macrón entonces ministro para facilitar
el desarrollo de uber en francia contra
todas nuestras normas contra todos
nuestros derechos sociales y contra los
derechos de los trabajadores mientras
los taxistas franceses protestaban
contra uber la filtración muestra que
macrón defendió el crecimiento de la
empresa en parís y se tuteó con el
cofundador biz cavani como ministro de
economía las funciones del señor macrón
les llevaron naturalmente a reunir e
interactuar con muchas empresas
comprometidas con el fuerte cambio que
surgió durante esos años en el sector de
los servicios que tuvo que estar
facilitado desbloqueando los obstáculos
administrativos y regulatorios la
empresa se ha visto salpicada por
acusaciones de acoso sexual violaciones
de datos y pagos insuficientes a los
conductores durante varios años hubiera
respondido diciendo que su
comportamiento pasado no estaba en
consonancia con los valores actuales y
que hoy es una empresa diferente